o sol se realiza mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um capacete 27
que estava como ficar e depois mostrado
do tutorial passo a passo
então é exposto usar desta maneira só
que eu pessoalmente gosto mais como eu
fica assim é aí sim diga nos comentários
como é que vocês gostam mas aí o tempo
deste projecto vai estar na minha página
do facebook que vai estar na descrição
você depois vão lá nem faz no facebook
na secção das fotografias e depois tem
que imprimir isto na escala de 250% é
isso então vamos começar em 1º e vão ter
que juntar as folhas do forma fazer a
mesma imagem que vocês viram na página
do facebook
para isso o inter terá algumas partes
brancas que não ficou nada imprimido
agora quase que vocês vão tirar isso vai
ficar ao vosso critério
o importante é que haja uma continuidade
do tamanho de uma folha para o desenho
da outra folha popular ou sacola tva mas
se vocês quiserem podem usar cola button
que também serve
depois de pularem tudo tem que
visualizar cada parte para não
atrapalhar mais tarde vou usar cola pva
e colar estas partes papel em cima de
papelão conversado
vocês podem tentar usando é que eu
propus ao normal das caixas só que eu
tenho aquela partida cuca por dentro e
isso fragiliza bastante então eu
recomendo que vocês compra e comprou um
texto assim que vocês vão encontrar à
venda nas procuras vocês agora pois tem
que individualizar as portas para ser
mais fácil cortar e convém que façam
isso em cima de um pedaço de madeira
usado aqui um x-ato por isso vocês forem
crianças peçam ajuda um adulto
não tem portanto com vocês o dobro em
por estas linhas
isso vai facilitar bastante o trabalho
de seguida para votar esta parte que vai
sair para fazer um dos corpos e vamos
estar só pra um porque em igual para o
outro são simétricos e tem que cobrar
pelas linhas também
esta parte aqui vai ficar a volta da
cpmf era muito importante aqui é porque
no triângulo ali à frente que vai dar um
time pra cá vou juntar tudo eu vou usar
colocando estou sempre usar coletivo
porque não sei que é mais rápido e
também é mais barata
com isto modo fazer um dos corpos e eles
vão ficar um pouco faz uma vez que tem
muita obra mas não se preocupem com isso
porque quanto mais irregularidades que
tiverem melhor para massa que eu vou
colocar mais para frente ou seja a massa
vai abrir melhor ao morro e assim vai
ficar mais resistente e um pouco de cola
que a frança só passar um detalhe na
proteção do nariz
depois coloquei a fita a volta da semi
feira é muito importante que a fita
fique bem apertada
o conselho que vocês ponham na cabeça e
vão ajustando a fita depois vai ver como
é que fica melhor na vossa cabeça vida
tem ficar mais para baixo ou mais para
cima e quando estiverem contentes com o
esquadrão por cola por dentro agora a
proteção no nariz que o preço é um pouco
mais no que agora vou colocar os corpos
e os veículos em um pouco empenhados
para frente mais ou menos 30 graus
internet para frente
mas claro que isso fica o vosso critério
agora vou misturar água com cola pma
para fazer uma mistura que vai ajudar a
curar este pulinhos a volta do conceito
dessa mistura com caíu uma parte cola
pva para duas de água mais ou menos
importante quando vocês com carlos
colinas cima do móvel tem que agarrar
bairro não estiver bem é porque você tem
que colocar um pouco mais de cola pva
nessa mistura
eu coloquei pulinhos em todas as partes
- nos corpos e coloquei dentro também é
opcional mas eu acho que é mais bonito e
também fica mais confortável e vocês não
vão ter aquela expressão escola é
contatar contra a cabeça em seguida eu
vou colocar uma massa por cima mas vocês
não quiserem fazer essa massa ou então
não quiserem comprar podem sempre com
capitolina ea volta dos corpos na parte
de cima também e pois podem pintar
depois desse passo agora na massa e usa
cola pva um pouco d'água e um pozinho
usado pelos pintores que usam isso para
tapar as rachas
feridas se vocês não quiserem comprar
que é uma coisa barata podem sempre
contar algum pintor que vocês conheçam
seus podar um pouco disso mais ou menos
a 'mãe' quilo grana
agora eu voltei que os pedacinhos de
papelão para ajudar a colocar a massa em
cima do que eu passei os força se uma
espátula
eu coloquei massa só na parte de cima ou
seja colocar tudo menos na fita que eu
coloquei a volta vai ficar assim um
pouco foi o importante é que fica é
cobrir todas as partes a massa para
interpretar isto e para não dar muito
trabalho mais pra frente na hora de
lixar usar esse um pincel que parece não
quiser que um pincel tem uma esponja na
ponta e com água e desta maneira e
ajudou bastante e ficou muito melhor o
resultado
se vocês quiserem podem passar a lista
logo na primeira camada e pintar porque
ficar com alguma irregularidade não tem
problema porque é um capacete e
comportamentos que o paciente vão para a
guerra e alguns ficam ameaçados mas eu
tenho que colocar mais uma camada ou
seja fiz o mesmo processo em duas vezes
está como ficou depois da segunda camada
e você consegue ver que é que ficou todo
o tempo diguinho na primeira camada dava
pra ver algumas coisas
agora vou usar uma marca contra pó e vou
usar dois tipos de lixo primeiro uma
lixa 120 eu acho que sem ter em conta a
incerteza e depois usa uma lishan água
que se chama muita gente disse que ele
chega água num dos vídeos
então eu vou confiar que usa esse
exemplo ele chega água e ela faz uma
diferença muito grande fica muito mais
lisinha em comparação com a primeira
lista que usa e amarelo e antes de
começar a pintar eu passei uma camada de
cola pva e deixei ficar por duas horas
antes de começar a pintar vou usar uma
fita de papel usada pelos pintores para
curtir os corpos e aquela parte dele que
ficou só com papel de jornal
eu gosto muito desta feita porque ela
não estraga e depois quando tirar não
vai retirar nada não vai ter a massa não
vai tirar o jornal porque ela não agarra
se muito a cair agora na hora da pintura
façam várias mãos é mais leve e aí fazem
mamão deixem ficar passando a mão deixem
ficar porque colocaram muita tinta logo
ela vai escorrer e depois pode sujar a
parte ficou só com o jornal agora
padarias que foi total e que use uma
esponja e depois usando a quinta dos
praia foi espalhando assim levemente
assim aos poucos é impondo muita tinta
logo porque o objetivo é que se vai ver
um pouco de tinta ficou a preto por
baixo podem ver fica assim completo
mesmo metal e até mesmo contente com o
resultado disso não estava à espera por
foi a primeira vez que eu pintei dessa
maneira
agora vou apresentar assim os detalhes
encontra isto na gaveta da minha mãe
agora se você não tiver a isso não tem
problema nenhum é só você encontrará uma
coisa com esta é a aparência é só ficar
assim estranho porque fica se com vários
olhos a bola é só você encontrará uma
coisa com essas peças não podem procurar
padrinhos pequeninas e claro que vai
servir também
agora vou tentar cumprir estas partes e
eu sei que algumas pessoas devem estar a
contar mas por que não tentar logo tudo
preta então isso é uma questão de
preferência eu gosto mais assim deixar
com proteção e depois quando passar a
esponja e não tenho
o que me preocupa muito é não sujar as
outras partes que é em si uma coisa é
opcional ou seja é mais o meu gosto mas
se vocês quiserem pintar logo tudo preto
pois por proteção para não sujar as
outras partes
é isso é com vocês e para finalizar só
falta pintar os corpos
o zac um spray branco e dei várias
camadas mesmo branco não estava a
agarrar muito bem então passaremos cinco
camadas e depois cometeria passado
várias camadas ficou demasiado branco
entanto antes disso já era um pouco a
evolução social do fio espero que tenham
gostado disso tanto como eu gostaria de
fazer se tiver bastante light então eu
vou fazer mais coisas do gênero se não
então fazer coisas finalmente vocês
gostam mais
para finalizar o vídeo estava de
desafiar o canal express getfugu
embaixada de inscrição deste vídeo para
fazer um escuro eu pudesse usar com este
conceito e esse disco tem que ser
retangular porque eu vou fazer um
circular mais para frente é isso então
promotoria ter tido até o próximo
mundial